hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the monday morning podcast
for monday
february 15th 2021 what's going on how
are ya
[Music]
how's it going oh happy day
happy day after van valentine's day
happy after valentine i can't [ __ ]
sing
um i didn't work out the lyrics
everybody valentine's day is over that's
great
you got through it you know she won't
put the screws to you and bring up the
[ __ ] pressure
what is oh bill's going in is he going
in oh he's standing up
he's taking off his coat cause he's an
old man and he was a little chilly
the coat is coming off i got something
to say
i'm an old man and you kids should
listen to me
i don't understand what is with the
ladies the [ __ ]
pressure constantly apply they were in
the full court [ __ ]
what do they call that what i don't
really think about basketball
full-court [ __ ] defense whatever you
call it full court press
huh who the [ __ ] knew kentucky was 5 and
13. i didn't know that
um they usually got that one [ __ ] guy
ready to just uh you know
explode you know john calipari comes
walking in he's like i'm tell you right
now lady
that kid right there is gonna be the nba
in one year he just has to come here
then he's going to go there i'm going to
go to the draft with them all right
it's called a spade of spade college is
[ __ ]
all right they're there they're building
entire [ __ ] wings of universities
offer kids with talent like your son
he's gonna be the nba millions of
dollars
his own secret line [ __ ] waiting for
him after every game all you gotta do is
get one season here
one season here in kentucky understand
me understand what i'm saying here
just have that kid come to kentucky
comes to kentucky he throws down on a
couple of skinny white kids from [ __ ]
depaul
and then he's gonna be in the nba it's
gonna be number one draft to get no more
draft
and he's going to buy you a [ __ ]
cabana 10 times the size of this [ __ ]
all you're living in but he's got to
come to kentucky you understand me
um that's usually what happens every
year then the kid goes and then that's
it and he [ __ ]
want it done john calipari goes the nba
draft there you go
you know with his little shark skin
[ __ ] suit
we had it all and then we [ __ ] it up
now i think they won the other day i was
watching the game
six and 13 6 and 12 whatever the [ __ ]
they are
um that is unacceptable unacceptable
what are you gonna do next make some
bourbon without
51 corn um
anyway yeah ladies with the [ __ ] oh
my god i love when you're married you
kind of love valentine's day in a way
you know i waited till today to get a
card
i was gonna get one the other day and i
was just like i ain't [ __ ] sifting
through all that [ __ ] so of course this
today i gotta go you know i gotta go
walk over to the uh
i go for my old man walks you know what
i mean it's important for a man of
a particular age to you know shuffle his
feet down the [ __ ] street you know
what i mean
stare down a couple of squirrels make
yourself still feel like a man
right um so i go down there to buy some
bounce
some downy some [ __ ] for [ __ ]
laundry i gotta get her a card right so
i go there of course all the valentines
not only valentine's day
cards all gone they're just [ __ ] gone
there's nothing left
so i'm like all right whatever i usually
just buy a blank one anyway i always
thought it was [ __ ] stupid
you're gonna buy a card that someone
else wrote a bunch of heartfelt [ __ ] and
sort of captured what you felt
and it's funny you know the amount of
[ __ ] that your woman gives you
for some reason they never sit there and
think when they're reading that card
that there's thousands of other women
out there
reading the exact same [ __ ] and putting
it down going
somebody else wrote it somebody else
wrote all of that who doesn't even
[ __ ] know you but you know what it is
it's not what it's about they
want you to take time out of your
[ __ ] day to go down there
read a bunch of them stand in [ __ ]
line
wait for those old people who are trying
to [ __ ] get their instant
[ __ ] camera thing developed and have
the manager come out to try to explain
to them that they've had the camera for
eight years and the technology has moved
on
so they give them a free [ __ ] ice
cream of course they don't they make
them pay for that too the corporate
[ __ ]
so i go down there and all the cards are
gone
so i don't you know i don't panic
all right i don't give a [ __ ] right what
do i do
i go okay there's no there's no [ __ ]
valentine's day cards left i'm just
gonna buy the stupidest [ __ ] card i
can find and i'm just gonna stare into
it
so you know it's like happy birthday mom
happy birthday dad
stupid [ __ ] like that i'm like that's
not gonna work that's not gonna work and
then i got to the congratulations
section
i'm like all right i'm seeing an
opportunity here so i saw one of these
cards
it was you know said congratulations
blah blah then you opened it up and had
songs celebrate good times come on
do do whatever right i'm like nah that's
not the one and then i just saw one that
said congratulations
yeah yeah woohoo boo boo that was dumb
[ __ ]
congratulations to you that's what it
said on the inside and then i just wrote
you married me
then i wrote in french i am the best
and you know it um
love bill that's what i wrote but then i
wrote a bunch of nice [ __ ] this side she
thought it was [ __ ] hilarious
and then i just realized that's what i'm
gonna do from here on out i'm going to
buy
the wrong card for the wrong key on her
birthday
i'm gonna i'm gonna get her a get well
soon just
i don't give a [ __ ] i'm sorry i [ __ ]
hate you know i like buying the blank
ones
because it's not about the stupid card
it's about what you
feel so you write it so what am i doing
you know you know what's funny is she
got me a blank butt
she went to some french shop she
actually took the time she took the time
all right
what are you gonna do okay but i'm
podcasting i'm paying the [ __ ] bills
here i don't got time to [ __ ]
no i kind of spaced i forgot i mean it's
[ __ ] stupid we've been together
forever what are we doing okay what you
do you think i don't love you
um we've actually had years where we
just didn't get each other's cards and
suppose you wanna just not get each
other cards
like that's our gift to each other and
it's [ __ ] great
um stupid ass goddamn holiday and we
used to always do like
we would go out to dinner like the
weekend after when there was like nobody
there instead of the
going out on valentine's day and playing
three times the [ __ ] cost
you know and just sitting there looking
at all those guys sweating it out
their last night of freedom the chicks
[ __ ]
full court press that's what i was
looking for
you know be [ __ ] great is if you go
to a valentine's day
a valentine's day uh dinner with your
girlfriend
and you bring john calipari
he just sits across and we just say
listen lady if you just hang in here for
one more year this kid's gonna show up
with a diamond ring that's gonna make
you think that you just made the nba
right you're just gonna hang in there
and not be a [ __ ] [ __ ] tonight can
you just do that do that for me okay you
give me 12 months 12 months of not being
a [ __ ] absolute pain in the ass
he'll show up next valentine's day all
right all right yeah he's right
you know then that bing bang boom you're
all done
all right enjoy your edamame
um yeah so anyway so then i'm coming
back
you know going by like the ten [ __ ]
cities
and then just one of those white church
singers i hear singing at this church
you know
one of those just more vibrato than you
ever want to [ __ ] hear in your life
i was like what is that [ __ ] sound
and then the breeze was blowing so i
could smell
the people in the tent city you know
just like [ __ ] nuts
it's [ __ ] nuts man that people have
to live like that
you know um
[ __ ] crazy right so the house think
it's funny that
they're living that way right outside of
a church and everybody's in there
singing about god and
and i don't know what can you do to help
those people
get them out of there jesus christ i've
pulled up to a stop sign and i'm [ __ ]
sitting there stop light i look over
this two people in a tent
with smartphones texting
and i had everything i do i couldn't
roll down the window be like hey how do
you charge those sticks
um you got something i don't know about
um you're just sitting there looking at
human beings
living in a tent on the side of a
[ __ ] street
it's unreal unreal see i see that right
and then i'm walking up the street
and what do i see i see [ __ ] the no
mass guy coming down the street big
dumb stupid [ __ ] baby huey looking
jackass right
you know what i mean big [ __ ]
looking like that guy from full metal
jacket with like
hair you know instead of buzzed down and
i've never given anybody
[ __ ] i've given people looks but this
you know what it was was the [ __ ]
[ __ ] i
he stays on the sidewalk and i have to
get off right
like i work for him so
he just walks by he's on the phone you
know didn't even make an effort to get
out of the [ __ ] way i'm clearing the
way for him like
i'm afraid of him or like he's like the
[ __ ]
governor or some [ __ ] so i just he
walked by i just go no mask
all right and then fatso waited like
until i was like 20 yards away he's like
yeah no mask
all right and then i wanted to turn
around and be like yeah no diet either
then he would have been yeah no hair and
i would have been like hey that hurts my
feelings man i didn't
i was just like whatever what am i gonna
do huh
punch him in his fat [ __ ] liver
dumb [ __ ] it's just what it is it is
what it is god bless these [ __ ]
doctors
coming up with these vaccines god bless
them okay
because there's just too many [ __ ]
stupid people out there
big if you just saw this guy big
stupid like this there's no god people
there's no
why would he make that
big stupid fat [ __ ] walking around a
pandemic
right down the [ __ ] street with no
mask on
i don't know if there is a god he just
doesn't give a [ __ ]
you know and i really want to talk to
him about his quality of work
anyway but when he said yeah no mask it
kind of [ __ ] pissed me off right like
like you know i'm the old guy telling
him to turn his music down
you know and like meanwhile like my
daughter's in every all my you know my
kids got to [ __ ] wear
masks that came go outside and play with
other kids because of
fat [ __ ] stupid [ __ ] like this guy
just stupid [ __ ] selfish [ __ ]
stupid [ __ ] selfish [ __ ] you know
something there's not there's nobody
worth anything that's in in the medical
field that will not tell you not to put
on a [ __ ] mask it's unbelievable how
[ __ ]
and that fat [ __ ] is gonna get this [ __ ]
and then go down to the hospital and get
treated
they shouldn't they'd be like oh yeah i
don't have to tell you fatty
i don't know you know what here's the
thing is i've been really working hard
you wouldn't know it from this podcast
i've been working hard to not
carry around that guy's [ __ ] so i'm
doing this because
i have nothing to talk about because i'm
doing nothing
like you guys i'm just staying in my
[ __ ] house
so um i gotta talk about this guy but
um you know the old me
would have thought about that guy
you know for like a week like literally
murdering him
not murder even in my fantasy i can't
murder somebody because as much as i
talk about god and [ __ ] i still have
that catholic upbringing what you're not
supposed to kill somebody right
um
but and after a week it would fade away
just because i would just now be mad at
somebody else
and then what would happen is i would be
i would be thinking about that guy
on and off for the rest of my life
sitting in my car
all of a sudden something would remind
me of him
and i would and i would just tell him
off to my car windshield for the rest of
my [ __ ] life
and uh
it's taken me my whole life to realize
how [ __ ] stupid that is i mean to say
it out loud it's ridiculous
but i don't know i need to keep saying
that because i can't [ __ ] do this
[ __ ] anymore
stand-up used to help with it because
that guy and i ended up getting a
[ __ ]
bit out of it something like that you
know but um
i don't know i got no [ __ ] idea uh
but i am excited this week because i i
do have uh
now that they've sort of opened it up a
little bit you know for these masked
distant socially distant shows
i'm at least back to kind of uh
[Music]
like being able to do a show every once
in a while so i got a couple of tune-up
shows i'm going to be doing out in
venice
and then um i'm going to do this benefit
got to make sure i'm on my game for that
people are paying for it like i said
for aj quetta and it's the uh nowhere
con
www.nowhere is it nowhere comedy is that
what it is
what the [ __ ] i said yeah
nowherecomedy.com
for tickets the show is on february 20th
uh i'm gonna dress up oh yeah
act like i'm back out on the road or
whatever you know what's funny i went up
to a buddy's place
um what the hell was it
i think i told you guys this went up to
watch a bruins game
four old guys sitting like 20 chairs
away from each other
he'll let her [ __ ] mask on it's
hilarious
and uh i remember i just went up there
and i saw
i just saw all the [ __ ] fast food
places on the way up there and i was
just like
[ __ ] i missed the road isn't that funny
just to look at that [ __ ] [ __ ] i can't
even eat anymore
like oh man i just i miss just being out
on the road going look at all this
poison what the [ __ ]
am i supposed to eat i actually miss
that doesn't make any sense
whatsoever so this is how bored i am i
actually
was looking up uh french cuisine right
just to have something different
to cook and i saw this amazing fight it
came in what the [ __ ] it was called
it's a breakfast thing let me look it up
let me look it up god knows we all have
the time to wait for me to do this right
it's not like anybody's got anything to
[ __ ] do anymore
um let's see here french
cuisine breakfast
dish uh madame
madam why would you say it oh there you
go
croque madame sandwich and i was like
look at that thing it's a sandwich it's
got a [ __ ] egg over
each on top so i wanted to learn how to
do and i said i said
i got mania look at this huh check this
out she goes oh yeah
croaked madame and you know what's
annoying about my wife i love her to
death but that
you can't [ __ ] discover anything that
she doesn't already know
i could find the most obscure band ever
on the internet she'll be like oh yeah
yeah i've been uh
been following him for three months i
was so excited to show her that that i
was gonna make it and she's just like oh
yeah i've had that before
i used to have that back in new york you
know
it's like all right whatever so anyway
i had a good day today a lot of quality
time with my my little son there
as he trying to rip my beard off he's
such a funny kid man
like little after having a little girl
just having a little boy man
they're crazy not crazy they're just
like
they just like plow forward
tear through [ __ ] like you know what's
hilarious
he doesn't like bibs you put one on him
and if he's in a mood not to have it
he just grabs it and starts yanking it
until the [ __ ]
it just the snap like it fails
he rips it off like a little hulk hogan
and me and my wife just sit there his
face gets all red he's like
yeah he just rips the [ __ ] thing off
and as funny as it is i'm like i hope
that's not gonna be
like uh
you know it's kind of funny now but
jesus christ
16 years from now when he asks us to use
the car and they say no is he gonna rip
my [ __ ] arms off
um funny but a little little unsettling
not gonna lie to you
so anyways i gotta go back with the fat
[ __ ] not wearing the mask you know
it's not just fat [ __ ] okay i don't
want to [ __ ]
fat shame machine right
pile on with the shame in here i drove
by a park the other day right
driving around i got nowhere to go
that's [ __ ] bored
right i drive by this park and there's a
whole there's a [ __ ] yoga class and
everybody's mad
it's like [ __ ] you know matt
everybody's mad is just like that's not
six feet apart
[ __ ] morons you know you could stay
in your apartment just do yoga why don't
you do that
i get that you want to get out put a
[ __ ] mask on go for a walk you can
have it down around you know around your
neck somebody comes by you just put it
on how [ __ ] hard is that
it's too hard it's too hard for all
these [ __ ] out here in l.a you know
they they're
still gonna go out you know
here's another thing too what is with
[ __ ] oh yeah everything's bugging me
now this has
i'm not mad at any of this [ __ ] i'm just
mad because i'm cabin fever and this is
all this [ __ ] is
so i'm just gonna go off on a bunch of
[ __ ] these what why do
joggers jog in the street
the [ __ ] is get on the [ __ ] sidewalk
[ __ ] idiots you gotta sit there and
slow down it's like you dumb [ __ ] don't
you know people are texting while
they're driving
so [ __ ] stupid
i don't know maybe it's just here in l.a
all these self-involved [ __ ] where
it's just
you know i mean it all started with
crossfit you know you can't just go to
the gym and work out
you have to run past other people who
aren't working out so they know that
you're working out
ugh you know
but i've been cooped up so long i
actually missed the crossfitters
[ __ ] idiots running down the street
with like a [ __ ] table and chair
whatever the hell they're doing why do
they do that
what is it about crossfit that it's just
like
that you gotta start running down the
street
you know i guess it's greener right they
i guess treadmills use up a lot of
electricity
i don't [ __ ] know i don't i'm sure
it's me i'm sure all of this [ __ ]
just [ __ ] comes back to me and my
shitty god damn i was in such a [ __ ]
good mood i don't know what happened
i don't know what happened
i know what happened you know what
happened i got busy i couldn't play
drums for a couple of days
and then that's it it doesn't clear my
[ __ ] head
and then i'm just i says i just been
pacing like
you know if anybody goes to a [ __ ]
zoo after this [ __ ] you ever see the
animals and they're in the cage and
they're just
walking around and around in a circle
that's kind of like how i feel and i
know i'm coming off crazy
right now and i'll tell you what you're
not wrong if that's your assessment
because i'm kind of going [ __ ] nuts
here um
yeah i've been home while today was my
day that i was home all day my wife got
to go out and go
i don't know go whatever the [ __ ] she
didn't want to go do
um all right so let me read some uh
advertising here the hell did i put it
do i have any advertising are there
stores anymore oh there we go
oh look who it is everybody it's butcher
box
you know it can be hard to find quality
meats that's what she said uh sorry
luckily today's sponsor butcherbox
believes everyone deserves high quality
humanely resourced meat butcher box
couldn't be easier
just signed up select your box and they
ship it right to your door every month
and when you sign up you get two new
york strip steaks and one pack of bacon
for
free who does not love free steak night
well
vegans you know
i'm sure you can find some people that
don't like it but hey me
i'll take their steak send them my way
butcher box no added antibiotics or
hormones
ever each box has 9 to 11 pounds of meat
enough for 24 individual meals unless
you're a size
queen uh packed fresh and shipped
frozen and vacuum sealed so it stays
that way
all right you can customize your box or
go with the one of theirs either way
you get exactly what you want butcher
box is a no-brainer
it's the best meat shipped right to your
door which means
one less trip to the grocers opt and you
won't see that fat [ __ ] without his mask
or the yoga class
options like 100 grass-fed and finished
beef
free-range organic chicken heritage pork
wild caught alaska salmon you don't know
what they're gonna do
and sugar slash nitrate free bacon
um it's the way meat should be
for a limited time butcher box is
offering new members two weeks
sorry two new york strip steaks and one
pack of bacon for free
in your first box just go to
butcherbox.com that's butcherbox.com
burr to get two new york strip steaks
and one pack of bacon for free
in your first box all right who's next
oh look who it is
look who's come back to the podcast it's
hymns
h.i.m.s you know the best way to prevent
more hair loss is to do something about
it while you still have some
god damn it why do guys turn to weird
solutions or do nothing
hey when they can turn to medicine and
science
solution for hims.com for hymns
f-o-r-h-i-m-s
dot com for hims.com a one-stop shop for
hair loss
skin care sexual wellness for men
it's time to write a new chapter one in
which you have hair
your dick stands up and salutes the flag
right and you got skin clearer than
[ __ ] canadian ice
uh thanks to science baldness can be
optional hims is helping guys be the
best version of themselves with licensed
medical providers and fda approved
products to help treat hair loss
no snake oil pills or gas station
counter supplements here
prescription solutions backed by science
science
it's funny people don't wear masks and
they don't believe [ __ ] doctors i bet
you know you start going bald you start
believing in those scientists don't you
hyms was created by a guy who knows some
men's health conversations are easier
some men's health
conversations are easier online than in
person no more
awkward in-person doctor visits or long
pharmacy lines
for hymns connects you to licensed
medical professionals online which could
save
you hours completely confidential and
discreet
answer a few quick questions a medical
professional will review
and if they determine it's right for you
can prescribe you
medication to treat your hair loss that
is shipped directly to your door
today hymns has given you their best
offer yet
hey by the way if somebody leaves it
outside your door in your apartment
building and you don't get it
knock on the door the other bald guy on
your floor uh if you're not happy with
your results after 90 days
hymns will give you a full refund and
right now my listeners can
get their first visit free
[ __ ] bill and right now my listeners can
get their first visit absolutely free
go to for that's for hims
f-o-r-h-i-m-s dot com slash burr
disclaimer must include this is why you
got to talk fast right anytime there's a
disclaimer
prescription project will hire an online
consultation with a health care provider
who will determine if a prescription is
appropriate reactions apply
restrictions reply see website full
details and it's important safety
information remember that's for hims.com
burr lastly but not leastly mvmt
movement watches mvmt mike victor mike
tango in a tiny apartment in southern
california two college
dropouts teamed up to create a watch
company that broke all the rules
with fair prices unexpected colors and
clean original designs
mvmt pronounced movement grew into one
of the fastest growing watch brands
shipping to over 160 countries across
the globe they're blowing up
now movement has expanded into blue
light glasses that protect your eyes
from your screens i gotta get a pair of
these
minimalist jewelry and more style
essentials that don't break the bank all
designed out of their california
headquarters
movement watchers have the look and
quality of a 400 to 500 dollar watch
you're paying for at the department
store
or like uh the ground magazine
um but cost a fraction of the price
because they were built
online and owned their process from
start to finish you get a beautiful
watch
shipped right to your door for free if
you don't love it you can ship it right
back for free
wait if you get a watch for free you
ship it back for finally these guys
making money
uh their new everscroll blue light
filtering glasses are a game changer
if you're in front of a screen all day
they can they can really help with eye
strain and poor sleeping patterns
if you want to elevate your look with
style that doesn't break the bank
then join mvmt and get 15 off today with
free shipping and free returns
go to mvmt.com again
that's slash burr mvmt.com been meaning
to get those
those blue tinged uh glasses
you know cause my eyes are going to [ __ ]
here
we can hang on here for a little bit
longer before i gotta get those giant
clap
everybody i know all of my [ __ ]
friends now they all quit drinking they
all quit smoking and they all have those
giant [ __ ]
you know recycled flat screen tv glasses
giant
big square
glasses and i'm calling it right now
that's going to be what they make fun of
in 20 years
from now like every like or maybe next
decade
i don't know in 20 years i think it's
always they always go back 20 years
right
in the 90s they did all the stuff about
the 70s boogie nights and all of that
[ __ ]
right then in the 2000s it was like
talking about the 80s and all of that
[ __ ]
and uh now the 90s are cool or whatever
that would be whatever so in 20 years
from now when they make fun of this
[ __ ] last
six seven years or whatever i think uh
the bell bottoms are gonna be those
giant
[ __ ] microwave side
size [ __ ] lenses that people are
looking out of
um anyway let's get to the questions
here
for the podcast all right well i haven't
talked about how my celtics have [ __ ]
dropped three in a row
good lord plus to the sons then they
lost to utah
and i don't even know who the [ __ ] they
lost to last time i watched the game
celtics schedule let's see who they lost
to
who did they lose to dude we got the
nuggets on tuesday but who the [ __ ] did
we lose to
see more
let's see here beat the wizard oh we
lost to the pistons
that's right yeah i like watching blake
griffin now you know now he's more of a
perimeter shooter the guy was like
[ __ ] hitting threes and stuff
he used to jump over people and dunk i
love when you watch an athlete at his
level you
know as he gets older he just changes
his game it's kind of like pedro
martinez you know when all of a sudden
he lost a little bit of
a little bit of heat on the ball you
know he developed a couple other pitches
created a new way to go around people
it's really amazing
um it's the people that can adjust they
stick around for a long time
so it was fun to watch him play even
though we lost um and the bruins i guess
lost to the islanders i don't even know
they had a game they played wednesday
and then friday i just assumed they were
off on saturday
according to my friends back home i'm
glad i didn't watch i guess we got our
asses
down there in long island although i
think the rangers should have got a
point
you know the islanders should have split
that two points with the rangers because
even though we beat the rangers two
games in a row they really put us
through the uh
paces that's like one of the best teams
we played all year um
thank god for marshawn scoring the
overtime winner for the 16th of his
career and then uh
a fight riddled game a fight riddled
game like from back in the day did i
already talk about this i can't even
[ __ ] remember
um shades of the bruins rangers rivalry
back in the 70s
there so who do the celtics got next we
got the uh
we got the denver nuggets coming up next
but i've been really enjoying watching
them
even though we're sort of like a like
kind of seemingly settle into a little
bit above 500 if not 500
the way we're playing but marcus smart
is out
who the bruins got next bruins schedule
brewing
shed oh we got the devils
we got the devils now okay now here we
go
my man trent frederick on the boston
bruins the last time they played he
wanted to go at it with pk subhan
going back and forth with him right
bk is a [ __ ] superstar he's like i'm
not getting off the ice because of you
but he did
say the video i saw he goes he goes when
i get the opportunity i'm going to beat
the [ __ ] [ __ ] out of you
and trent goes ah why don't you go make
another workout video you [ __ ] loser
you gotta check out the hawk nhl [ __ ]
talking man it's [ __ ] great
so um we're gonna see uh
we're gonna see uh if that goes down
this next game
i will tell you um i don't know how to
say the guy's name
he's got one of these one of the
defensemen for the bruins right
you go with those [ __ ] days where it
looks like kz said something i don't
know how to [ __ ] pronounce it right
let me see if i can look it up he got
into a fight on uh
on friday and he just beat the f
he beat the [ __ ] out of this guy man it
was very impressive
he was beating this guy so bad that the
guy like he like ducked his head down
and the guy just caught him with the
[ __ ] uppercut and that was it i think
it was jacob
not jacob's bro who was it i don't know
who it was one of our big defensemen and
it was good to see that we have someone
like that
for the next time we play a team like
the [ __ ] blues if they're still
the way they are dude why does david
pass
posture knocks [ __ ]
his picture it looks like a 1970s
yearbook picture
i'm not saying he looks like a weed
dealer but he looks like you know he
could definitely get you some
um
great to have him back by the way of
course so that's what i've been doing
i've just been watching every bruins
every cell this is the most bruins in
celtics games i've been able to watch at
home
that is one upside i hope i don't bum
you guys out man i've been having a fun
time teaching my daughter how to ride a
bike
i have been having that but um i just
want to just see yet another person for
whatever reason
not just going with the flow and wearing
a mask at this point it's just like
dude do you ever want this to [ __ ]
end
you know but i mean he's a fatty i mean
you know did he care that other the
other people in the house they lived
with maybe wanted some cookies too
is he sat there eating a whole [ __ ]
sleeve of them
maybe that's why he didn't wear it you
know
he's so into food that during this
pandemic he probably forgot that
a number of times that he had the mask
on he put his slice of pizza into his
mask and then he just felt bad
so he's like [ __ ] it i'm not wearing it
i don't know trying to find empathy for
that guy
all right recipe website all right dear
billy pumpkin head oh come on guys
feeling down this week can't you can't
somebody just say you know
billy not that ugly can we can't you
just give me that you know
all right i have heard you express your
displeasure
with internet recipe websites oh my god
that happened to me again today
i was trying to learn how to make
something and says you know since i've
been a kid
french cuisine has always interest me i
don't
give a [ __ ]
just tell me how to make it
why are you turning it into a [ __ ]
mini series there
you know what i'm gonna look up a
[ __ ] recipe let's just you pick a
[ __ ] recipe
i'm gonna do some i'm gonna do the most
basic one peanut butter
and jelly sandwich
recipe literally
the name of the [ __ ] dish is the
recipe
let's see how long somebody can drag
this out
all right clicking on it
here we go all right you know what i
found the one
this is one they just it just says
spread the peanut butter on one piece of
bread
spread the jelly on the other side put
the two pieces of bread together to form
a sandwich
toddler adaption cut off crust before
serving
all right i think they covered all the
bases all right i got to go a little
further than this
let's just look up uh
there we go let's go little um
spaghetti spaghetti sauce
recipe here we go here we go
i spelt spaghetti rum okay here we go
homemade spaghetti sauce okay
and here we go all right this spaghetti
sauce recipe
may be the first thing i learned to cook
completely by myself
when i was really young wow that was one
of the worst sentences i
jesus as i got better at cooking and
baking parentheses
and because i loved it so much and
parentheses
i can specifically remember two recipes
my mom
would let me make all by myself
this homemade spaghetti sauce and our
family favorites
for some reason then it says pumpkin
chocolate chip cookies
she'd be nearby for supervision but it
was a huge confidence boost for me to
cook all on my own
i don't give a [ __ ]
and an even bigger confidence boost when
my older brother said they like the food
emoji this homemade spaghetti sauce
recipe has been a family staple for as
long as i can remember
i've been i've been waiting to figure
out how to [ __ ] make it since as long
as i can remember
it's like i'm reliving your childhood
here it's really simple
and the flavors are fantastic
this is one of those meals that always
tastes amazing just keep going
going and going and going all right that
actually wasn't that bad
sort of a quick thing look at her she's
a sweetheart too
oh god welcome i'm lauren a mom of four
and a lover of good food i'm sorry
lauren
just in a bad mood you know what i mean
you know what you know what's funny that
fat [ __ ] didn't wear the mask he's
probably sitting at home right now
eating the spaghetti sauce
wiping his using his mask as a napkin
he's gonna tuck to the front of his
shirt
ah where can i get all these little
fuzzies off this windscreen okay
here we go anyways he said
uh and having to let me start this over
again
uh i've heard you express your
displeasure with the internet recipe
websites
and having to scroll through a long back
story about their childhood look at that
or some unrelated bs before they show us
the recipe
i found the answer to your problem on
reddit
someone made and shared a website that
you can copy and paste
the url of the recipe page into and it
strips away
all the clutter to just give you the
recipe here is the link for the website
i'm reading it to all of you
www.justtherecipe.app
ah another million dollar idea
if i would just listen to my complaints
and actually try to you know what you
guys listen to my complaints whatever
i'm pitching about
right you [ __ ] make it you make the
money and i'll buy it i don't give a
[ __ ]
uh you're welcome and go [ __ ] yourself
from delaware thank you so much
www.just2recipe.app hang on a second
oh my god if there was ever an app made
for me here we go
www dot just the
recipe
[Music]
was it dot app i never know how to spell
recipe
i before e except after c
r-e-c-i-p-e did i spell it oh i spelled
it
did i spell it right i spelt it
r-e-c-i-p-i-e
oh god bill just the recipe
just the facts bill jesus christ this is
taking me longer to type than it does
for these [ __ ] [ __ ] to tell you
to make a peanut butter and jelly
sandwich
uh recipe recycle
and what is it dot app slide oh dot app
a-p-p
a-p-p just the recipe
get just the ingredients and directions
for any recipe no life story no pop-ups
no email list
paste the recipe well how do i get to it
ah jesus christ all right whatever you
guys can figure it out you're young
you got your whole lives ahead you have
time to figure it out
um all right minimalist living okay for
those who didn't listen the last time i
was making fun of those people that live
in small houses
not that it's a bad thing to do i think
it's a great thing to do but actually
going into that house and having to
listen to that person
[ __ ] sit there like they crack the
code of living
i don't know i forget what i said i
probably said something [ __ ] up and i
imagine this is somebody who lives in a
little house
gonna give me [ __ ] all right dear billy
acetate
i heard you [ __ ] on tiny homes a
couple of podcasts ago
as an owner of a fabulous 400 square
foot tiny home i was triggered
um i'm sorry that i got 99
of america oh i'm sorry i'm oh i'm so
sorry that
i in 99 of america can't afford your 4
000 square foot old house
hey buddy buddy i was you
okay that i just didn't accept a [ __ ]
tiny house
go write some jokes and get on stop
acting like i'm some trust fund kid
um he goes i have everything i ever
needed
consolidated into one small area this is
why i don't want to go into these
people's houses
if you came into my house i wouldn't sit
there and tell you talk to you
about the square footage and all the
stuff i had i would ask you what you
want to drink
this you're proving my point if i went
into your [ __ ]
house i'd have to sit there and listen
to you telling me how [ __ ] great it
is the whole time
uh minimalist living isn't just about
housing it's a lifestyle
see see see what i said i share a smart
car with my wife and i
own i only own three outfits of clothing
even my dog is small uh
let me guess you probably waste food and
are too good for leftovers
[Laughter]
dude let me tell you something i am a
[ __ ] animal
my wife gives me [ __ ] i go into the
goddamn fridge like a [ __ ]
bear do you know i was on my way to eat
something and there was a little salmon
cake left in this little sad plastic bag
i'm like that might be going bad i don't
give a [ __ ] i don't want to waste it and
i just [ __ ] ate it and it tasted like
[ __ ] and i still finished it
so [ __ ] you and your little [ __ ]
house and your oversized ego
um anyway how about you start you know
what if everybody's like you then little
houses are for quitters
um how about you start thinking about
the environment and your overall
impact why don't you go break down some
more boxes for nia and leave us
minimalist alone
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] sir i'm sure now that you have
you know only three outfits you have
time to sit around and think about what
your dream is and why don't you go after
it okay
that right there is the exact i
literally said on the podcast i wouldn't
want to go into some guy's little
[ __ ] house
because i'd have to listen to his
[ __ ] ideology and then you
send me an email i was making fun of the
ideology not that you're doing it
at what point did i did i put my [ __ ]
house in your house's face i didn't do
it
i love when that happens come on i want
to hear from more you little house
[ __ ] holier than now [ __ ] [ __ ]
i love how you think because i live in
this [ __ ] house
that i don't you know what my house even
looks like that you think that i don't
[ __ ] recycle
anyway any [ __ ] i don't want i just
bring it
over to the [ __ ] homeless people or i
sell it on ebay you don't know me you
[ __ ] [ __ ] you're in this your
little ass [ __ ] house and all of a
sudden you're better than me
[ __ ] you all right enjoy your walk-in
closet go [ __ ] yourself
all right uh lady listener here oh i
love when i hear from the ladies
uh lady listener here dear bill
dear billard bald
that's like a name out of a fairy tale
everyone enjoyed the party except for
old billard bald
he crawled out from underneath his
bridge um
all right you're my favorite comedian i
love the podcast i'm a lady listener
who's getting
a bit fed up however oh jesus you spend
so much time ranting about how women
need material object
is it possible that that's not all women
yes but that doesn't make it
uh funny just the ones you're into wow
everybody got triggered today i'm not
trying to dr phil
analyze you here just make a point um
you're not making a point you're
presenting your opinion
all right so don't stop patting yourself
on the back and you're back before your
bra snaps
um in the podcast you always advise men
to get the most beautiful early draft
pick female possible
then seems surprised when her
personality is [ __ ] oh god this woman's
mediocre looking too i honestly don't
know where you meet these women who want
stuff so bad and oh and now she's
putting herself on a [ __ ] pedestal
and acts so nasty unless you are
literally just seeking attractiveness
in that case isn't that on the guy who
picks her
not on women as a gender oh oh i see
what you're doing you're you're saying
that only beautiful women are acting
that way
oh i get it yeah that's right only
beautiful women want to be taken out on
valentine's day they're the only ones
that pressure you for a ring
they're the only ones going on amazon
buying more [ __ ] than they need it's
only the beautiful women
plain jane's like yourself ah you're
down to earth anyway
every beautiful lady i know works hard
pays her own bills oh jesus this fairy
tale and
struggles to find a man who doesn't live
with his parents at
age 30 or addicted to porn or video
games
all right i okay the second half
addicted to porn and video games i'll
give you that
all right but let's let's take it down
here
let's take it down here with all these
beautiful oh they all work hard they all
pay the
everyone's a [ __ ] astronaut i know uh
that's our side of things
that you seldom address
um all right well then can you look at
yourself critically consider i just said
yeah most guys are addicted to porn and
video games
i'll give you that i'll give you that
all right but you be honest with me
is it one of the first questions you ask
a guy when you meet him at a bar is what
do you do for a living
and i get that you know you don't marry
some [ __ ] loser
right but if i [ __ ] look across the
bar and what am i i'm supposed to
[ __ ] get with what
some chick with a face like a cuckoo
clock you know what
why when are you women going to just get
over the fact you know some of you that
you're not as good looking as the other
ones
if i can do that as a guy you know
i mean i don't if you're looking for
sympathy for me because you're the
female version of my face i mean i don't
know what to tell you
welcome to the club all right at least
you get to keep your hair
he goes maybe it's time to retire the
all women want material objects bit
or at least add some female perspective
then you can get ladies laughing too
oh god jesus christ because you're not
laughing
because oh you know what this was the
classic
you're my favorite comedian i have a
great sense of humor and now i'm going
to take the piss out of you oh jesus i
walked into that one
um listen there's plenty of other
podcasts out there if you don't like
this one don't
[ __ ] listen to it all right but i
don't hear you [ __ ] you know there's
plenty of
[ __ ] guys [ __ ] that i make fun of on
here you somehow
don't seem to hear it the only you know
you're just like that classic
douche that goes to a comedy show now
where everything's a joke until it comes
around to your neck of the woods
all right i'm sorry i guess you didn't
get enough free drinks bought your way
and uh you and all your unicorn
beautiful lady friends who all work hard
and pay your own bills all right
okay okay yeah and every guy i know
[ __ ]
uh respects women and helps old ladies
cross the street get the [ __ ] out of
here
uh we're both animals okay and um
i don't know i guess i will retire the
all-women one i don't say all women but
i just
you know i lump it into a group
you know i'm sure you know yeah i know
you know when you go down rodeo drive
when you go into a mall and all of that
[ __ ] i mean come on
who thinks buying most of that [ __ ]
you know
who do they put the [ __ ] pressure on
in advertising
in like a relationship thing there is
not one [ __ ] holiday out there
lady where the pressure is on you that
you gotta [ __ ] wow the guy
the holiday does not exist doesn't exist
buy her the [ __ ] buy her the [ __ ] buy
her the [ __ ]
um all right but you know
i know listen listen like i've always
said you know i can find you a white guy
with a big dick that can dunk a
basketball but that doesn't make it the
norm does it
um all right anyways so whatever i mean
i i'd love to meet all these beautiful
ladies that you hang out with
that pay their own bills and struggle to
find a man
but i understand that part struggles who
doesn't live with his parents at age 30
and is addicted to porn and video games
i mean you [ __ ] nailed it there
[ __ ] nailed it i'm not getting
offended
you're kind of lumping all these guys in
into uh
you're kind of doing what i'm doing
aren't you maybe you want to co-host
this we'll do a little co-hosted thing
you can [ __ ] trash guys i don't give
a [ __ ] um
oh god all the sensitive people maybe
you want to [ __ ] that guy in his little
house
he's a minimalist he doesn't have time
for a laptop he won't have porn or video
games you guys can live happily ever
after
all right uh girlfriend caught snooping
found something hard to explain okay
here we go here we go let's hope this
person has a sense of humor
hey there you fancy freckled [ __ ]
[Music]
uh i get the title uh
may sound a little bit a little
click-baity but follow me
on this one i've been seeing this girl
for about a year
in a few months
for about a year and a few months me
personally i would have said i've been
seeing this girl a little over a year
but i get what you guys are doing now
you write awkward sentences trying to
trip me up because i'm not good at
reading out loud
anyway and it's been nothing but a day a
dream come true for the most part
uh we are very different as i'm fairly
committed to my work
and have a [ __ ] ton of motivation
parentheses
thanks to you actually hey you see that
playing jade i'm not all bad
[ __ ] um well she has a bit of a lazy
personality
um but thankfully i've been pushing her
to improve her habits while she helps me
unwind
and takes my mind off work so i can
relax well there you go yeah
she's got to turn it up a little bit you
got to turn it down overall we pair
really nice
okay okay what can go wrong what can go
wrong
what can go wrong um
all right now that the context is out of
the way i got a new phone on december
31st
the girl's friend spent the night at my
place and when i woke up i left for work
everything was going great until i got a
text from her
and it said you haven't been with any
other girls have you
i told her no that i'd swear in a bible
i thought i was
it was maybe some insecurity creeping in
and she wanted some reassurance then i
got a voice memo of her bawling her
[ __ ] eyes out oh no
she said i know i shouldn't have done
this and it was the wrong thing to do
and i'm sorry but i went through your
old phone and i found text messages
between you and another girl this was
back in june and she sent you nudes
oh boy now here's where it gets tricky
bill
she wasn't wrong but it wasn't me
cheating my buddies and i have
participated in some stupid contests for
years that we called
chub fest it's a stupid kid thing that
we should have
grown out of but it's been tradition
basically we all have to try and get
nudes from the fattest chick possible in
the span of two weeks
winner gets 300 ow dude
through the years we didn't want our
girlfriends to know for obvious reasons
oh yeah dude yeah jesus what were you
thinking
but we are all good-looking dudes who
would never cheat with the 250-pound
girl
when we all date sevens to nines oh my
god
the chick who wrote that other email
right now is [ __ ] their head's
spinning around
it's a stupid thing for boys and it is
great for a laugh albeit it's a little
mean
yeah come on man but we never would
consider being unfaithful to our
partners we had them
dude you can't do that to people even if
you weren't in that relationship don't
[ __ ] do that
uh this entire thing woke me up to how
immature and shitty this is i really do
feel shame for this bad joke
taken too far i told her i can explain
this but it may sound like a lie
so call my little brother ask him what
chub fest is and it should clear it up
she said she would rather hear it from
me so i explained the whole thing
oh my god could you even look her in the
eye
seems like she understood and was no
longer heartbroken and believe me
i guess it might have been too [ __ ]
dumb to make up
that said my question is this how do i
move forward
i don't know dude
i don't know i yeah dude this is above
my pay grade but i'm going to keep
reading you
she expressed how apologetic she is for
snooping through my phone
going through um now i feel bad i was
making fun of that fat guy not wearing a
mask you guys think i hate fatties i
don't i just hate people don't wear
masks if you're fat and make funny
wearing fat but i would never do that to
somebody
come on man um
i was going to say that's low-hanging
fruit but that's kind of a fat joke too
isn't it oh geez
she's expressed how apologetic she is
for snooping through my phone going
through all of my messages since
[ __ ] march of last year and
understands it was wrong
but surely this can't be a one-off thing
right i can't really expect her to not
invade my privacy again can i
if i do do i look like a [ __ ] to her
subconsciously i'm totally lost bill and
i appreciate some wisdom out of that
shiny noggin you got
uh love the podcast you've inspired me
to improve my habits and attitudes
towards life for years and i really do
owe you a lot
my success all that said go [ __ ]
yourself
um you got to talk to your girlfriend
you got to talk to her and just say how
wrong you were
about that other [ __ ] and then you got
to burn a lot of sage man that's that's
some [ __ ] bad karma
um but then you kind of gotta
i mean what do you don't have a leg to
stand on here she snooped and
she found a bunch of naked chicks right
um
i don't know dude so then you guys all
looked at the naked fat chicks you just
laugh at him
yeah listen i'm a [ __ ] but jesus christ
dude that that's really uh that's
really i don't know that's uh i don't
like bullies i don't like that [ __ ]
i don't want to tell you dude i would
just [ __ ]
look you said you looked at it now
you're embarrassed by it maybe this is a
good thing because that happened
but um
i don't know how to fix this one man
i mean she snooped and she found
something
so like that one i would just say
either you gotta move on or you gotta
live a squeaky clean life
one or the other and then eventually
she's gonna feel like she doesn't need
the [ __ ] look
i guess that's it uh you gotta you gotta
you gotta sit down and talk to her
try to rebuild some sort of trust there
and uh come on man what the [ __ ] chub
fest don't do that [ __ ]
um all right adam curtis documentary
um okay dear billy bandaid
about six months ago a listener wrote in
suggesting you watch a documentary
called
hyper normalization i doubt you have yet
because
i think if you had you'd mention it on
the podcast yeah i i don't want to watch
what i already sense
okay if i watch this [ __ ] it's just it's
like
i can't watch that stuff because
nobody else is questioning it i've been
that guy that watches that [ __ ] and then
tries to talk
to the people all you do is bum them out
all right they're in the matrix they're
watching the kardashians they're
watching the super bowl
and just just let them just
stay there i will read this if you guys
cause some of you
might want to be into this but i can't
watch this type of [ __ ]
uh the filmmaker adam kurz just released
his latest documentary on his youtube
page where
this guy's doing god's work by the way
uh where the others
live as well wait i missed this here
the filmmaker adam curtis just released
his latest documentary on his youtube
page
where the others live as well all
meaning the other documentaries are
there
uh this new one is fascinating and i
really urge you to check it out it's
called
can't get you out of my head he's very
well respected in the uk the best part
of his documentary is that he gives you
lots of information
perspective and footage of different
parts of history
you would otherwise not know much about
now that's interesting
if he's just going to make me paranoid
you know
i mean i can do that on my own and this
new one can't get you out of my head he
takes you through things like
radicals in west berlin and bloodshed in
communist china
remind yourself of this when you wonder
how he gets away
with talking about the cia the british
empire and banks
while receiving a wide bbc broadcast
despite those subjects coming up he's
not a conspiracy theorist
and never regarded as one okay okay so
he's okay
check it out mate love you and love the
podcast i'm gonna watch that
because it seems to not get branded is
that there's got to be some sort of
levity to it but if it's just like
there's lizard people and shape shifters
and
they're putting this chemical in your
food it's just like okay
i don't know how to grow my own apples
so like
all right sorry about that i hit the
wrong button i was trying to see how
much time i did
um yeah i don't uh if it's all that
shape shift to stuff i can't watch that
[ __ ] but if it's it's somebody that's
like
can talk about it in a more like
balanced way that you can actually get
on a mainstream thing i'll definitely
check that out
uh once again the guys the filmmaker is
adam curtis all right
um all right that is it that is the
podcast
all right now let's not let's not
[ __ ] go down this road people every
once in a while i haven't had to do this
in a while
that lady there's taking the [ __ ] that
i'm saying about women too seriously
the guy in his little [ __ ] little pig
little pig let me in house you know he's
taking what i'm saying a little
too [ __ ] you know
personally what a [ __ ] that guy was huh
you know can you imagine being a bigger
[ __ ] than your house
how do you fit all that cuntiness in
that little house um
he's actually way ahead of the game i'm
going to give i'm so props that guy i
would love to only have three [ __ ]
outfits or whatever do the einstein
thing i would [ __ ]
love to do that my problem is is i'm
sentimental so i have all these [ __ ]
t-shirts
that i got at gigs that people gave me
or they give me a backstory and give me
i can't get rid of this [ __ ]
um i can't tell you how many times i've
walked in my closet and just want to
just
grab handfuls of stuff take it down to
the tent city
and then and then but what happens is is
people they just
they just keep sending you more [ __ ] i
can't remember last time i you know it
was [ __ ] up
when i was living on a futon
you know no manager no agent just
flaming out in my
professional and personal life eating
spaghettios
right
you know i had to buy everything the
weirdest things you get past a certain
level and you can actually afford things
then everybody wants to give you [ __ ]
but then you also kind of realize and
then they're hoping you're going to wear
it and then walk around like a [ __ ]
you know free advertising i don't know
what it is just everybody always gives
you like a [ __ ] t-shirt or some [ __ ]
when you get if you if you're into
t-shirts get into show business
because you will have more free [ __ ]
t-shirts than you know what to do with
um i should do that you guys want some
t-shirts maybe i'll do that
um bill's uh bill's free t-shirt
giveaway
then i have all these [ __ ] suits that
i never wear anymore
but i wore them when i was on letterman
or i wore them on conan back in the day
and they mean something to me but now
that i'm such an old comic they're
completely out of style what the [ __ ] do
i do with those
i'll be honest with you little house
people i wish i never went down this
[ __ ] road but i'm so far down this
road i don't know i don't know what to
do now
you know i'm sitting here right now and
i'm looking at i have a little miniature
double bass drum kit
that you set up that somebody gave to me
when i was like in germany
and it's like how do i get rid of that i
went all the way to germany
and there was somebody who gave a [ __ ]
not only enough to show up to the show
they gave me a gift
what do i do with that thing now i can't
throw it every time i look at that thing
i think there's some guy in germany gave
me that how [ __ ] cool is that
then i'm also thinking i wish i never
had that because now it's just something
[ __ ] else i have sitting there
i don't know i got to tell you for all
the [ __ ] years i've been in this
business i only have one closet
full of [ __ ] it's all i do have
um but there is a lot to say about the
minimalist lifestyle i'm just [ __ ]
around okay i know there's a bunch of
great women out there i married one
okay but i'm a comedian i make fun of
[ __ ] and i know there's not every fat
[ __ ] person out there is not wearing
a mask
and i know when they eat their food
they're smart enough to take the mask
off
but where's the comedy okay do i get all
[ __ ]
upset when somebody calls me billy
pumpkinhead
or billiard bald he called me billiard
ball did i get all [ __ ] mad
you know i didn't damn no harry me in
show business
i didn't do that did i have [ __ ] left
fancy freckled [ __ ] alliteration it's
insulting
come on people grow the [ __ ] up all
right all right that's the podcast
go [ __ ] yourselves even the beautiful
women that pay their own way and can't
find it
all right that's it uh i'll check in on
you
on thursday go bruins go celtics go [ __ ]
yourselves